décision sur qui devrait diriger
l'État russe finit par
toujours pour les citoyens de la Russie, ils
exercer ce droit de choix avec
au scrutin secret direct et
c'est le chemin et seulement comme ça
peut-être pour ceux qui
ou la personne qui pourrait
diriger le pays
eh bien, d'un côté, ils disent un lieu saint
il n'y a pas d'espace vide et il n'y a pas de personnes irremplaçables
d'autre part bien sur
ma responsabilité est aussi
pour
faire des recommandations
les personnes qui postuleront
bureau du président et cela se passe dans
tous les pays du monde je n'en connais aucun
exceptions et bien sûr le temps viendra et je
J'espère que je peux dire quelque chose comme ça
ou telle ou telle personne à mon avis
digne de diriger
un pays aussi merveilleux que le nôtre
patrie russie